Swati Gupta who's a faculty member at
Georgia Tech she would tell us about
individual fairness in hindsight so be
excited to be here and to be a part of
this and the famous cluster in the
summer this is joint work with a
wonderful collaborator which I calmly
who's a faculty at UIC at the School of
Business and so after I didn't stock I
think it sets the stage stage perfectly
for individual fairness and extensions
to other cases and in this case
specifically we will talk about
extensions to time and so I I don't
really need to go over this but this was
really nice quote from yelling Chen and
Lee whose paper which I like nearly all
theories of fairness are founded on a
quality of some sort the heart of the
issue rests on clarifying the quality of
what and a large amount of work by
amazing people in the audience and in
particular will focus on equality of
treatment and so we are also thinking
about individual fairness and Hinds
individual fairness and the concept that
similar people should be treated
similarly and okay so in classification
setting I think this is a pretty
standard example where you could have
people who are very similar in the
context but classification could take
why these different decisions for them
and that might be construed as unfair
and so people have sort of motivated
that's your your fandom stochastic
classifier so that the decisions are
probabilistic and maybe that in the
probability is at least we can say
they're fair but again there's a
question of you know what does
randomness mean and does that actually
what do the probabilities actually
qualifiers like you know what does it
mean to have a probability of a decision
for a particular individual and I'm not
going to get into that so I'm going to
view individual similarity as individual
fairness as Lipschitz constraint so if I
have two decisions and my background is
optimization so I always think about
polytopes and utility is that I want to
maximize over the Polydor so if I took I
had a cost factor and that gave me that
vertex then if I put up the cost factor
it could give me another
vortex which would be very different
from each other even though the costs
were only perturbed slightly and the
individual fairness would say that you
know maybe you should take decisions
which have which are closer to each
other and so it would enforce a
Lipschitz constraint on the set of
decisions that we have and every context
decision restricts the decision for some
similar context and the question that we
want to answer is or ask is what about
time so imagine now decisions that are
taken over a period of time for instance
people going to banks and there were
some very nice talks about loans but in
in this talk I'm going to treat loan as
a toy example so please don't think me
about hello its but but of course happy
to discuss any questions so suppose
there is a bank that wants to give loans
to individuals and these individuals
come over time then are you is it fair
to be constrained to taking similar
Doane decisions for those individuals
over time or can the individuals could
diluents change over time dependent on
what the bank maybe learns about those
individuals default rates right and so
let's let's think about certain very
natural temporal extensions which is
first finest across time and fairness
across time is basically the the
simplest extension that one could think
about is as context so imagine people
are contexts and they are coming over
time and I say come over time maybe the
decisions that we take for them are
bounded by some Lipschitz constraint
over the distance between the contexts
and these Lipschitz constrained could
maybe get relaxed over time maybe you
get a weaker constraint with respect to
decisions that happened way in the past
so what does it look like let's say I
want to take a decision between 0 & 1
and a context see bond arrives and I
decide to take a decision of 0.5 then
when the next context arrives within
some in some space then maybe the
decision at c1 it constrains the
decision for c2 and now I can take maybe
slightly more of a decision but that's
constrained by the decision of c1
and Lipschitz nests may be relaxed over
time as time passes so when c3 arrives
maybe blue has a weaker constraint a
larger boil and the red dot enforces a
smaller ball and so the decision was are
taking to be at the intersection of
those two but note that as similar
contexts arrive over time if the same
context arrives again then it is
constrained to get the same decision so
you cannot take a different decision
even because the distance between those
two contexts would be the same it would
be zero so fairness this knife extension
of fairness across time enforces the
constraint that for the same individual
you must take the same decision
irrespective of when they arrive in time
and that is a little bit problematic
when we think about learning so for
instance if a bank enters in your market
doesn't know if age is positively or
negatively correlated with default rates
then if we're wrong individual was given
a loan then that mistake must be
repeated forever a more broader societal
example if similar issues map to similar
decisions how do we reach laws and
policies that get better over time so
for instance if we had very constrained
laws maybe about human cloning genetic
editing marijuana laws then how do we
sort of as we get more information about
a particular technology how can we
change laws over time and so we want
some sort of flexibility with fairness
and flexibility in the decisions and
this I want to highlight a quote by John
Steinberg in one of the talks he gave
recently about safety and lightness of a
system so it would be particle it would
be very fair if the system kept making
the same decisions for similar people
over time but then it would sort of not
be a life system it would not be able to
operate so we want to basically strike a
balance between learnability and being
able to operate an online learning
setting and have enforce some sort of a
fairness and a proposal in that respect
is individual fairness in hindsight so
equitable treatment relative to the past
but
not necessarily with respect to the
future right so if you look at the
Lipschitz constraint that we had in the
previous slide then we can break it down
into two constraints one that says that
you have a lower bound dependent on
decisions that you've taken on the past
and those decisions produce a lower
bound other decisions that you're taking
now and an upper bound of the decisions
relative to the decisions taken in the
past right and we call the first notion
as individual fairness in hindsight and
you'll see a lot of connections to many
systems in the society and why this
notion this relaxation makes sense for a
learning setting okay so in the context
of the loan example for instance what
this constraint is saying is that let's
say t1 somebody gets a $50,000 loan then
at the next time period if a similar
individual arrives and they get more
loan than what they initially had a more
conducive decision right then this is
considered fair under our definition of
individual finest in hindsight so the
point is that this person will look at
decisions taken in the past before them
and then complain about the decision
that was taken for them or feel that
they were treated fairly so as long as
decisions become more conducive over
time it's great people in the past will
less frequently complain about the
decisions that have been taken in the
future so we allow we allow the
relaxation that people in the past will
not release complaints again at t3
somebody gets $80,000 that's great
because it's more conducive than the
decisions that similar people got in the
past but somebody getting seventy five
thousand and after that that's unfair
because they'll be like oh but somebody
similar got a better treatment than me
and so why didn't I get that but I mean
it seems like there's a ratchet effect
here
you know if the economy has a downturn
or something and I simply have less
resources or I'm thinking about social
services and you would have a solid
basis for putting back
but imagine thing about scenarios where
people were given varying kinds of
prices let's say uber rights used to be
very minimally priced there would be
priced cheaper than public transport but
now they've increase the prices and
there is this growing sense of being
treated unfairly by like even though
they were burning through their funding
initially right but had they done the
opposite had they started with something
which was less conducive and move
towards a more conducive decision people
would have been great like you know this
is great uber is doing well as a company
and so the point there would be that the
distance that we would think between
people who have between white and
non-white individuals the distance is so
small that maybe the bank should not
have differentiated and an individual
affair in hindsight policy would be to
actually give them many similar loans
and and you'll see an example of this I
can come back to this question in a few
slides
okay so again
diagrammatically consider the context
that I've arrived in the past will pose
lower bounds and contexts that arrive in
the future and so if it's a similar
concern text then it will just give you
a lower bound now and it will not give
you the ball constraint but it's not an
upper and a lower bound it's just a
lower bound right so you have the option
in this set up to improve decisions over
time and make different decisions for
the same context as
comes over there okay so let's think
about the prevalence in society of these
concepts and and a lot of inspiration
that we drew from many existing systems
for instance one major motivation came
from directionality in law so in law
there is a notion of status you see
where you stand by things decided so
it's very seldom it happens but it's
very seldom that people will complain
about something that is done in the
future and try to reevaluate a case that
was decided in the past but it's more
often the case that cases in the past
decide the treatment that cases in the
present will get right so to stand by
things decided decriminalization laws
are often constrained as being fair when
something was recognized as an illegal
activity and now it's been
decriminalized then they're often
construed as fair about society markdown
promotions so markdown proportions is a
standard practice in a lot of gravity
management firms and studies where
consumers view perceptions of having
promotions that go deeper with time so
promotions where you have subsequent
discounts they're considered fair in
fact price exploration of items in the
beginning is considered largely unfair
and that's that's what one of these
papers talks about by these are Bolton
at all rent control and stabilisation
again it's it's an approximate situation
it's not exactly individual finest in
hindsight but the fact that the rents I
have a controlled increase or a
controlled decrease and if the rents are
decreased then tenants don't complain
and if the rents are increased they can
only increase by a particular margin you
cannot have a high amount of non
conduciveness in their decisions
what about isms so there's a growing
culture of what about isms where people
complain that oh you're talking about a
politician from my party but what about
the politician from your party who got a
more conducive decision beforehand and
somehow that sets the trend that you
know society should be probably more
conducive more accepting dough conducive
treatment
so with all of these examples let's now
think about some math and going to learn
ability and utility maximization under
individual fairness in hindsight and
first I want to consider a very simple
scenario where there's a bank and there
are two types of contexts let's say blue
and green people and they're drawn
stochastically from a distribution and
we want to maximize the utility from the
decisions where some amount of loan is
given to these people and they either
have propane a tendency to default or a
tendency to not default which is
captured by that function f so let's say
there's one fourth fraction of the
population is blue 3/4 of the population
is green and the the context is modeled
as minus 1 and plus 1 the Lipchitz
constant is 0.25 so we can only differ
in the decisions for these two contexts
by 0.5 so you and C 1 defaults and C 2
does not default right so if you take so
ideally you only want to give loans to
this set of people and that will be the
red dot there at 1 but because your
loans are constrained by individual
similarity constraint your loans for the
this group of people have to be at least
0.5 so that's what individual similarity
gives us that the loan has to be at
least 0.5 because the difference between
these two populations is small right but
since you want to maximize your utility
maybe you look at the maximum set of the
population and you sort of cater your
decisions towards that ok now let's look
at individual fairness over time and
fairness across time where we're trying
to maximize the utility of these
policies as small contexts come in and
try to find what's an individually fair
rule so there's no learning involved
currently it's just a utility
maximization of policies and what we
realized was that for these two
definitions and if you look at very
small time horizons it is possible that
you get different utilities so the
maximum utility is under
individual fairness in hindsight can be
more than the maximum utility that you
get under individual fairness across
time and a simple an example to show
that is the following where you have
maybe only three contexts arriving and
you know they're going to arrive and
because you suspect when you see the
first context in the fairness across
time policy because you suspect that the
next arrivals might be from the green
population you maybe assign them alone
of half-and-half in anticipation of this
one but in fairness across fairness in
hindsight even if you suspect that more
of the greens will come because they're
the higher the majority in the
population you can assign them zero and
you can increase that to be on point
five because that's a more conducive
decision and that's allowed under
individual fairness in hindsight but
interestingly over time as limit goes to
infinity the maximum utility you can get
by any of these policies where you have
individual fairness or individual
fairness across time or individual
fairness in hindsight the maximum
utility I think yet from each of these
constrained policies is the same and
that was that's an interesting I thought
an interesting proposition all right so
let's get to the setting of learnability
of utility so now we have a notion of
fairness across time and how does that
impact learner ability of utility in a
learning setting so let's see if the
first context is given a loan of some
amount in fairness across time then
overall overall time periods it is
constrained to get that same a same
amount of loan right because fineness
across time it does not allow you to
take different decisions for different
groups of people
once you've resigned to a decision you
cannot change the decision over time so
moving away from that in fairness across
hindsight we proposed a very simple
algorithm that's quite intuitive so what
it does is we call it caffeine
it's cautious fair fair exploration so
you start with very conservative
decisions at the beginning which are not
conducive so extremely conservative
decisions at the beginning and once you
have enough
evidence of how the world's operating
then you can sort of move monotonically
to opinions of policy that's also
individually fair so the learning phase
until sufficient evidence so in the lone
example may be explored with an epsilon
amount of loan for all populations and
gather enough evidence so learn until
you have sufficient evidence and once
you have that evidence then you can
monotonically increase the loan amounts
for populations that is not defaulted
and you can increase this to a set of
policies that enforce the individual
fairness constraint without time so
let's see a simulation of this so let's
say again you have those two sets of
population groups 1/4 and 3/4 with the
fraction of people and as each of these
come you give the same amount of loan
epsilon to all of these members and once
the exploration phase ends and you
realize that actually this is the group
that defaults and this is the group that
is not default then you can
monotonically increase your loan amount
to 0.5 here the best individually fared
will is 0 and 0.5 because remember the
Lipchitz constant allowed you to only
deviate by 0.5 right so now because the
majority defaults and the minority does
not default so your best utility
maximization rule is 0 and 0.5 and so
you get more atomically increase because
even though you violate individual
fairness here you don't violate
individual finest in hindsight because
decisions have become better over time
so more useful think about our
contextual bayonets so which is kind of
case here as well so what's the set of
policy I should be thinking about
[Music]
the contexts are sort of coming
stochastically to you
and for each context you do need to give
our decision for contextual bandits I
think you can allow yourself to not make
a decision and not pull an arm continued
continuum of arms but here
really in the initial phase so whenever
you increase your decisions for a
particular armed individual fairness in
hindsight will basically say that you
cannot decrease the decision back so
your increase has to be it's not
reversible it has to be very thought of
like when you have enough confidence in
maybe you can increase that I see so I
guess that really two small questions
about what is I are you restricting
yourself to consider a subset of
mappings from context to some real value
to 0 1 or just arbitrary mapping and
then second is you know why should we
word relationship between say 0.5 and
point 7 s there's some monotone
structure in learning because like
giving a small s in hindsight imposes a
monotonic structure in the decision in
the direction of conduciveness
and maybe you say that getting lower
amount of loans is more conducive
because when people are not indepted and
maybe right like it's better for the
mental health or something
and that's fine like so it it depends on
the notion of conduciveness is the
monotonicity the arms are contexts are
stochastically drawn here so they're not
coming in adversely the decisions are
the decisions have to be Lipchitz with
respect to the distance in the
constraint in the contexts and be allow
for any map
[Music]
any map between the contacts and
decisions
as long as it's no shits with respect to
the similarity metric
excuse why this morning's like in the
learning thing is let's say learns that
the vac minority in a population a
default more and it's ignoring all the
systemic reasons why that may be
happening systemic reasons but then it's
like oh okay
I am justified now and you know if the
distance metric recreates race
right so so we did think a little bit
about what if your confidence about the
world changes or what if something
systemic about the world changes and one
interesting sort of idea that's again
seen in the law is that maybe the law is
operated in a certain way and then there
was an increasing confidence that the
society is no longer what you thought it
was and maybe those laws made sense like
50 years back 100 years back but they
don't know and then legally there's a
case of first impression that happens
and after that you sort of set a new
precedent that's followed right so so
that's that's a great question and maybe
some extensions where you have you be a
high cost and then you're able to change
your direction so you sort of break I'll
be like a high cost which is there may
be the cost of finding the case or
something and then you're able to be a
break away from that precedent
so maybe switching setting where you
want to follow you want to satisfy
inertial fairness in hindsight but maybe
there are certain break points you're
allowed like case witches or catch
angels where you can break the
constraints to sort of incorporate new
evidence that you've got it
but yeah they open lick I think this is
like a just sort of a start making a
decent work
be kind of along these lines you could
even call that a different context once
you account for sort of like laws
changing or linking us tidal shifts and
then even like the same person who has
the same attributes who arrives later
maybe you observe some new attributes to
them or maybe your metric change to our
time and maybe you realize that people
who were considered similar should not
be maybe the this example that we saw
where African Americans have more
biodiversity than cross racial groups
right so all open questions
all right so that's how cafe explores
and then exploits and one of the
questions that one could also ask at
this point is how how conservative do
you need to be in your decisions right
so you might be too conservative and not
gain any evidence from the world right
so I might give zero loans to people or
I might get five dollars and everybody
sort of does not default on that and
they give every everybody gives five
dollars path so it's my epsilon or my
most conservative decision is is too
conservative that is not get sufficient
evidence to make decisions in the future
for instance you know maybe already
search stopped because the laws were too
strict for that and there was no
exploration there was no information
that you could get from those small
decisions then the question is how
conservative do we need to be and the
problem is that with fairness and
hindsight aggressive explanation in the
beginning will enforce the constrain
that you have to adhere to that
increased amount of loan or that
increased amount of conduciveness of the
decisions and it's it's an important
trade-off where how small can you get
while gathering sufficient evidence to
enforce regret formally speaking to get
low declared formally speaking and how
right and and you sort of resign
yourself to those large Epsilon if you
come in to them initially and so we
formalized that in by understanding the
care divergence between populations so
if you're KL divergence might go to zero
as your loan goes to zero so you cannot
distinguish between those two
populations at all but as if the rate is
nice enough then you can get order log t
regret if the rate is really small then
you get something some person regret
bounds and we also give matching
instances just to talk about order
optimality of these bounds
and another sort of so that's that sort
of the main theoretical theorem that we
have and with this I wanted to also
mention GDP I well data subjects have
access rights and where they can
question the algorithm about you know
why was this decision taken for me and I
we thought that cafe was an interesting
example where it gives me a sequence of
lower bounds from previous decisions and
a decision-maker could just say that you
know because I had to take these
decisions for these previous context
data right this is why I had to make
this decision for you and this aspect of
trying to explain online learning
algorithms I thought was is also
interesting and an open area to explore
that you know how can you sort of
quantify that you know now I have enough
evidence to treat you in a particular
way and tell those and make that
transparent to people so with that I
finished 15 minutes early but I think
that's okay because you're always eager
to go to lunch I guess the way you
framed this including like the title
hindsight you're focusing on a narrowing
time but it seems to me that you know
equally important is a sense of an arrow
of progress or generosity or whatever so
it's it's one thing to say that giving
you more loans is that's nice for you
and of course I agree that letting
people marry each other is a step upward
and human freedom but of course you know
people disagree about these things
you know especially in public policy you
know five replace income taxes with
carbon taxes or vice versa is this a
move upward or downward and so if I let
you do this if I impose about in one
direction is this a ceiling or a floor
and so I don't know that's I'm a little
confused I process it sometimes is that
our notion of conduciveness just changes
over time as you know maybe the director
from media changes or maybe the mayor
policies change or maybe the way our
education system change changes right
like we we change a notion of what's
more print yourself what's what's a
fairer goal to reach and maybe that's
okay just a comment to is you
specifically mentioned decriminalizing
marijuana as sort of a example of a
progress moving forward in cases like
that you also have issues of like
amnesty for people like for context in
the past that want to now like
reevaluate like wish you can think of as
the opposite of hindsight so so those
are less frequent Dharan cases very
president is said and has to be met
going forward do you see that as like an
anomaly within this directional law okay
I have one small question so the usually
the better out with them is you know
adaptive exploration we thought about
tournament formulation this fairness
across time constraint that may be
amenable in this time so one of the
ideas that we mean thing about is
switching switching like constant number
some degrees of freedom where you can
switch or some cost that you can bear
while breaking this constraint and
switching your direction and that should
but that would still constrain the
number of monotonic non monotonic
decisions that he can make over time
right so if you switch then maybe you
break the monotonicity you come here and
then but you pay a cost for that maybe
your budget on how much violation you
can have but the fact that right now
people sort of monotonic non
monotonically changing decisions all
over the place I think that's something
we want to avoid and enforce more
structure and exploration although
you're just that's like basically spa
program right like it's a big very
subjective swamp regret maybe maybe you
should get me more about it
yeah I haven't heard the term but I've
heard switching less than airiness why
again
[Applause]